far cadere un gattino o far cadere un
iphone ten
ciao a tutti benvenuti
oggi nuova challenge in cui dovremo fare
delle scelte difficilissime e anche voi
dovrete farle con noi nei commenti sono
proprio curioso di vedere voi che siete
fare ci sono le scelte più difficili al
mondo vedrà e sempre per curiosi delle
tue risposte le migliori risposte e le
vostre risposte voi dovrete giocare con
noi nei commenti prima di iniziare il
figlio di una cosa non velocissima mio
bellissimo libro bellissimo stupendo
queste sono le date dei firma copie
mi raccomando è un'occasione unica per
incontrarci come ho già detto se
prendete il libro nella libreria vi
daranno il passo per fare la fila prima
però potete anche prendere un altro
ebreo o su amazon e in ogni caso ve lo
firmerò non vi preoccupate se avete il
libro 53 sono felicissima di vedervi
tutti siamo felici che ci sono anch'io
quindi segnatevi le date gli orari la
via è tutto e ti vediamo prestissimo e
ora siete pronti
mettetevi comodi patatine occorre io il
mio equa
iniziamo subito con la salle c'entrano
ma non devo gestire una vostra risposta
nei commenti preferiresti essere in
grado di teletrasportarsi dove vuoi
può essere in grado di leggere elementi
rispondete voi nei commenti
tu cosa preferiresti un'altra brutta
teletrasportarsi crino però mi
piacerebbe di più leggere elementi così
posso sapere che cosa c'è qua dentro
basta chiedere a leggere le mete una
ricerca più profonda nella mente non è
non è una risposta sì o no il per
leggere
quello che dice tu quando tu mi dici voi
questo questo 12 questo e poi dopo in
realtà è tutto il discorso dietro che
non finisce mai si è capito non vi dico
cosa preferire io io preferire le tele
trasportarmi dove voglio questa domanda
gioco dove ricordando lo piccolo
non ho mai capito perché un sacco di
persone sollevano scegliere per
scegliere leggere la mente perché se ci
pensate bene se fossimo davvero in grado
di leggere la mente nella mente di
un'altra persona ci va ci sono talmente
tanti pensieri uno dopo l'altro che
erano velocissimi che forse non
capiremmo nemmeno questo è quello che
stiamo sentendo invece chiesti catanese
trasportarsi dove voi oggi voglio andare
a diventarlo san giusto ci voglio andare
a tokyo si puo vendere ai caraibi allora
utilizzò per la vostra risposta nei
convegni che se penso che dovresti
famiglia
forse ma se avete scelto l'estremamente
spina sì sì perché nei commenti simili
numero 2 preferiresti trovare l'amore
vero o trovare una valigetta con 5
milioni
quindi il vero amore o 5 milioni
scrivete la vostra risposta nei commenti
è il perché non è un po difficile
rispondere a questa domanda ho visto che
ci siamo già trovati
quindi secondo me se scegliamo tutti e
25 milioni 55 su 10 che stiamo a posto
non dobbiamo la sensazione cosa ce l'hai
già fai finta che non tu non mi conosci
in una idea della mia esistenza ok io
non esisto e viceversa
cosa sceglieresti 5 milioni mentre
subito in ferie vacanza non fare niente
mangiare da solo e triste solo cosi non
fanno la felicità ha però se questo cibo
compri felicità
allora si può considerare anche vero
amore scrivete nei commenti 16.000
turismo tale giocata basta a mangiarti
tutti i litorali
allora io ho fatto tanti conoscenti così
solo se non esistessi sceglierei sì il
vero amore perché con 5 milioni su sei
solo non ci si sono più triste sono tre
preferiresti
essere trasportato 500 anni nel futuro
può essere trasportato 500 anni nel
passato
beh per me questa domanda insomma la
risposta è abbastanza semplice però
scrivete voi cosa preferireste su questo
preferisco fermata del futuro
cinquecento anni fa forse messi
abbastanza male pessime per gli esseri
umani ma per qualsiasi essere vivente ai
500 anni nel futuro poi con la speranza
che magari ci siano ci sono già i viaggi
nel parliamo del passato per mafia
napoli visitare tutto quello che vuoi
quindi non penso che si saranno farò
però 500 anni nel futuro se è ancora il
mondo sarà in piedi tv di questo
teletrasporti ma dove sei
forse su marte forse ci trasferiremo su
marte io sento il futuro tutto ok voi
cosa scegliete è perchè scrivete nei
commenti numero 4 preferiresti mettere
fine alla guerra o mettere fine alla
fame nel mondo
mettere fine a una guerra con la
speranza che poi questa vado a
migliorare anche alla fame nel mondo
poi cosa scegliete scrivete nei commenti
numero 5 preferiti essere la persona più
ricca al mondo può essere immortale
da rispoli prima tutti ma sempre
vorresti sempre comprarsi tutti i
ristoranti essere immortale per vedere
non mangiare di tutto ha scritto in modo
di tutto per sempre
adesso scommetti che si faccia cambiare
idea poi come sempre
allora non mi interesserebbe essere la
persona più ricca al mondo sinceramente
perché hai un sacco di responsabilità e
devi andare in giro con le guardie del
corpo ti possa però essere immortale non
mi piacerebbe perché vedresti tutti i
tuoi cari morire tutti o anche appunto
tuo fidanzato to morire beh io sono
immortale allora forza e poi sono sempre
da piccola
vidi questo film che si chiama l'uomo
bicentenario non so se l'avete mai visto
ma comunque la storia di questo punto
che vive per 200 anni e fa vedere la
sofferenza appunto che la sua compagna
muore e poi sua figlia vive sia il
trauma che muore est della sua compagna
e anche la figlia perché poi la figlia
cresce invecchia e poi muore per lui
avendo 200 anni in entrambe le morti e
fa capire che essere vivere a lungo e
sono essere immortali e perdere i propri
cari non ne vale la pena quindi vi ha
fatto cambiare idea
proprio io faccio cambiare idea se
preferisci essere ricca
sì questo che le cose del corpo e tutto
è purtroppo sarebbero molte le sue
verità ma meglio che veder morire tutti
forse no perché voglio bene e tu hai
cambiato idea
il numero 6 preferiresti sposarti che le
celebrità di tua scelta o sposarti con
come si dice craxi in italiano con la
persona per cui hai una cotta
invece l'ho già tutto due ce la facciamo
vado smetta tra l'altro c'è un'attrice
che abita le piace tantissimo
chi di caprio si è innamorato allora
indovinate quale tra queste celebrità
che esistono qualche pianse vitali
indovinati dobbiate dominate vediamo
essendo milano scrivetelo nei commenti
allora vi do la risposta avvitare piace
tantissimo lei emma stone bellissime
alema stone ha scherzato il bastone che
la veloce futuro e motorio che accorcino
nord di capri questa volta faceva una
serie su permettono al forte di bard
daniel radcliffe questo è l'attore
inglese che non mi ricordo come si
chiama
l'unico interessante per me in questa
lista canzone a nardò di capri o daniel
radcliffe massaua il brutto non li chi
dall eletti ma che non è bruce speciale
moretz e le botnet stavo scherzando
a questo punto non è uscito giunti a
bene però in ogni caso non salirei la
salubrità perché non ho idea di come
stiano caratterialmente cristo la
bellezza di 17 preferiresti avere il tuo
lavoro dei sogni però una paga molto
bassa o un lavoro che o di qualche fan
pagano molto bene dai rispondi tu
scrivete voi nei commenti e forse certa
per il lavoro che amo almeno al lavoro
cioè sono felice nel corso della della
vita e del lavoro piuttosto che un
lavoro che odio ma molto pagato
voi cosa preferireste noi che abbiamo
avuto varie esperienze lavorative
diciamo un lavoro che amo e dico
decisamente un lavoro che amo però che
viene pagato meno è però si sia capitato
di fare dei lavori che assolutamente non
ci piacevano mai capitato di fare un
lavoro che abbastanza importante diciamo
però non era il mio sogno e non era
quello che volevo fare e ho capito
appunto che è meglio rischiare
rincorrere i propri sogni che fare tutta
la vita qualcosa che non ti piace in cui
non stai bene però 8 preferiresti
essere in grado di respirare sott'acqua
o essere in grado di vedere attraverso i
muri a voi cosa preferite per strada
forza vedere attraverso i muri perché
sott'acqua alla fine quando vai due
spalle basile spears sott'acqua pure
sarebbe interessante cioè una bella
immersione non hai bisogno di bombole
d'ossigeno teli tranquillo quindi quella
che piace molto guardare dei fondali
quindi sempre con la maschera e allora
perché il disegno delle tre versetto che
c'hanno l'altra voce che magari
sott'acqua ci vai solo si vede che
vitali una persona indecisa vero
prestino in questi qui non riesce a
decidersi io in tre secondi subito sti
quel pacco così pesciolone possono dare
tranquillo anch'io e sederi respirare
sott'acqua per i soli non mi interessa
vedere attraverso i muri 3 vicini i
nostri testa del 3 bellissimo puoi
andare al mare esplorare vedere che
vedere attraverso i muri così posso
credere a dovermi nascondere le cose da
mangiare ma ecco perché
numero 9 preferiresti passare una notte
in una casa infestata oppure passare una
settimana da solo nel bosco rispondi
tour questa volta io so già quale io lo
so già mi sembra strano che tu lo sai
già allora io sceglierei passare una
notte in una casa infestata anche se
sicuramente farebbe paura perché sono a
casa infestata di fantasmi per me mi
intrigano stato queste cose fare licola
videocamera filmare i fantasmi a cercare
i vampiri invece una settimana nel bosco
non sopravvivere immagini mezz'ora
scegliere la settimana nel bosco per me
fa paura
fantasmi che cosa spy una settimana nel
bosco da vero relax nella natura si
porta mondani legale in bosco
settimanali mi mangio il minidisc il
quale scegliereste vitale fifone per i
fantasmi queste cose paranormali fanno
un sacco paura a me nobel intrigano un
tacco quindi sceglierei la casa
infestata e voi cosa s'è diretto 10
preferiresti
essere spider man o estremo
allora cosa preferiresti sì perché tutti
mi spezzo tutto ciò mi piace di più un
ragazzino lo guardavo di più spider man
non riesco a capire le cose non mi
piaceva di più quindi voglio essere ok
secondo me spiderman decisamente hulk
non so cosa ti serva a diventare grosse
girante forte a meno che non devi
spaccare mai ma che se so perché ma
staccare i muri verde rosso e nero in
poi volare grazie alle ragnatele cui
voler da una parte all'altra
scegliete scrivete nei commenti mero 10
11 11
oddio far cadere un gattino o far cadere
un iphone ten
ma tutti ma stiamo scherzando
dio c'è vabbè iscriversi alla vostra
risposta nei commenti
cioè nel senso non è che preferiresti
devi in questo caso di per farsi
scegliere il gioco che devi professor
sceglierne uno cioè qual è il meno
peggio ci dicono ma io mi chiedo se
veramente qualcuno qualcuno pensa
veramente si preferisco buttare di
gattino che il mio telefono c'è
se qualcuno pensa che il proprio iphone
ten valga più della vita di un gattino
mi mi fa rabbrividire questa cosa
veramente c'è un oggetto inanimato che
non soffre vale più della vita di un
gattino che soffrirebbe tantissimo
sfracellato a terra spero veramente che
la maggior parte delle persone
sega iphone ten ovviamente un oggetto
costoso ma non vale la vita di un essere
vivente
oddio mi fa paura che se questa domanda
perché vuol dire che qualcuno magari
assetto di buttare cattivo espresso
dell'hard lo zio comunque era ovviamente
che buttiamo l'iphone
mettiamola rally fondo tutto è
interessante numero 12 preferiresti non
essere mai più triste o non essere più
arrabbiato arrabbiato tristezza si sta
spostare un riporto una cosa mentre
arrabbiarsi non porta non porta a nulla
sì concordo quando sei triste non è per
forza una cosa negativa infatti io a
volte non lo so anche leggendo su
internet non essere mai triste divise
per essere allegro e positivo non è vero
la tristezza è un'emozione come un'altra
e
non bisogna reprimerla anzi se non puoi
magari poi esplode invece arrabbiarsi
sprechi un sacco di energie
arrabbiandosi causi magari cose negative
causi qualcosa cioè amal esperienza
anche a livello di salute
sì ho anche per altre persone quindi
decisamente non essere più arrabbiato
sarebbe molto butta sempre pace e
l'amore
e voi cosa scegliere anche questo è
molto interessante preferiresti essere
saggio può essere ricco saggio e come
mai la richiesta puoi averla anche da
stupido non è che i soldi di dire caro
l'intelligenza o l'essere saggio quindi
assolutamente essere salto chi è che
sceglierei essere saggio perché serve
molto di più poi andando avanti nella
vita voi cosa scegliereste scriveteci
nei commenti
e la saggezza magari vi porta pure ad
essere ricco poi domo falsi come
conseguenza allora vi sarà la fine del
gioco fateci sapere se vi è divertito
sapere le nostre risposte e sapere voi
se la maggior parte delle persone
consesso direbbe scriverti sì tutto nei
commenti noi non vediamo l'ora di vedere
le vostre risposte vedere le vostre
motivazioni magari si fate cambiata e
ora vi lasciamo un pò 4 casellini
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
challenge video divertenti slime
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao ciao